.
Tschau.
- Trag Sorge zu dir.
Achte auf dich und bleib sauber!
- Ich probiere es.
Oder so.
Trag Sorge zu dir.
- Gleichfalls. Merci.
Achte auf dich.
Ist gut?
Einer muss vorangehen.
Tschüss zusammen!
Ich habe zum Glück
noch die Jungs hier.
* Sanfte, melancholische Musik *
Auf und davon nach Uruguay:
Die Emmentaler
Ruedi und Susanne Althaus
wollen eigenhändig
eine Ferienlodge bauen.
Unser neues Zuhause.
Einfach noch ohne Haus.
In der letzten Folge bereiteten sie
alles für ihre Auswanderung vor.
Damit kann man
zwei, drei Häuser bauen.
In Turbenthal im Kanton Zürich
übergab Josef Almeida das
Bed and Breakfast an seine Mutter.
Sie kennt es, aber jetzt
schaue ich nochmals genau hin.
Mit ihren Kindern
brachen sie nach Kanada auf.
Dort wollen Almeidas
ein altes Motel übernehmen.
Und an der Nordsee
versuchen Sacha und Brigitte Kunz
ihr Glück mit einem Imbisswagen.
Eher im Spass sagten wir:
"So was sollten wir haben."
In Basel-Land
räumte die Familie ihr Haus
und zog bis zum Umzug in den Norden
zu Brigittes Mutter.
# Uf u dervo.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Schüpbach im Emmental.
Die Kochtöpfe müssen mit.
Im neuen Leben in Uruguay möchte die
52-jährige Susanne Gäste bewirten.
Die Küche ist ganz klar
die Domäne meiner Frau.
Da halte ich mich raus.
Sonst kommt das nicht gut.
Sonst ist da
Konfliktpotenzial vorhanden.
Ruedi und Susanne
wollen eine Posada eröffnen,
eine Art Ferienlodge
mit Restaurant und Swimmingpool.
Jetzt räumen sie ihr Einfamilienhaus,
das sie vor 20 Jahren
selbst gebaut haben.
Hier in der Schreinerei des Vaters
ist Ruedi aufgewachsen.
Hier hatte er
als Bauschreiner gearbeitet,
bis es ihn irgendwann
in den Kosovo zog -
zur Militärmission mit der SWISSCOY.
Zurück in der Schweiz nahm er 2006
eine Stelle beim Bund an.
Wir geben viel auf:
das Geregelte, die Sicherheit.
Das alles haben wir nicht mehr.
Die Präsenz- und Arbeitszeiten
werden länger sein.
Das hoffen wir jedenfalls, denn das
würde bedeuten, dass es läuft.
Das andere gibt man auf,
aber ich denke ...
Die Freiheit, die wir nachher haben,
die Zeit für uns selbst,
das möchten wir nochmals erleben.
Das war bei Susanne und mir
der springende Punkt,
um es zu wagen.
Das Haus, in dem sie ihre drei Jungs
aufzogen, ist bereits vermietet.
In sechs Wochen bricht Ehemann Ruedi
nach Uruguay auf.
Susanne kommt nach.
Sie arbeitet noch ein paar Monate
länger in der Schweiz.
Das ist das Studio,
das wir für uns behalten.
Ich bleibe hier, bis ich im August
auch definitiv nach Uruguay gehe.
Etwas Geschirr und ein paar Möbel.
Viel mehr lassen sie nicht
im Emmental zurück.
Können wir jetzt
das Bett noch zerlegen?
Können wir.
Du musst sagen,
wann du sägen willst.
Jetzt. Aber ich will nicht sägen.
Du sägst.
- Nein, ich lasse sägen.
Stellen wir es auf die Terrasse.
Ich hole noch
ein Verlängerungskabel.
Jetzt geht's ans Eingemachte.
Fürs neue Leben
gibt es auch ein neues Bett.
Wir werden es verfeuern.
So können wir grillen
und haben alle was davon.
Wir kannten uns vier Monate,
dann wurde ich schwanger
und wir heirateten.
Das ist nächstes Jahr
schon 30 Jahre her.
Krieg und Frieden.
Genau.
Mit allem, was dazugehört.
Zusammen haben sie
schon viel geschafft.
Nur nicht die Finger einklemmen.
Sogar eine Trennung
haben sie gemeistert
und sich wieder zusammengerauft.
Jetzt krempeln sie ihr Leben
noch einmal komplett um.
Er lebt dabei auf.
Ich finde es schön,
dass er die Möglichkeit hat,
im "Alter" wieder
seinen alten Beruf aufzunehmen.
Das wird manchmal
nicht einfach sein, oder?
"Im Alter" ...
- Wir sind nicht mehr 20.
Das klingt,
als ob wir in Rente gehen.
Ein letztes Mal den Familienalltag
mit den drei Jungs geniessen,
bevor das alte Leben
vollends in Kisten verschwindet.
Kommst du noch zum Kühlschrank?
- Ja, wir wissen jetzt, wie's läuft.
* Idyllische Musik *
Das Ehebett ist schon Geschichte.
Was bleibt, ist die Glut.
Wer möchte ...
Wer schneidet die Spareribs auf?
Tom, Spareribs aufschneiden.
Merci.
Michael, Gesundheit.
Lukas, Gesundheit.
Schön, dass ihr hier seid.
Santé zusammen.
- Gesundheit zusammen.
Es ist schön, dass sie hier sind.
Das ist super.
Solche Events
werde ich sicher vermissen.
Man stellt sich vor,
wie es werden könnte.
Aber wie es dann sein wird,
sehen wir, wenn es so weit ist.
Aber wie gesagt,
es ist nicht greifbar.
Nein, das ist es wirklich nicht.
Die greifbare Nähe ist weg.
Die ist weg.
Da ist einfach eine Distanz.
Die kleinen Dinge.
Ja. Und einfach ...
Das Zuhause.
Das ist schon ...
Das fehlt dann schon.
Ja.
Wir können euch nicht mehr spontan
zum Abendessen einladen.
Das können wir schon, aber ein
paar Tage oder Wochen im Voraus.
Eher Monate.
- Ja.
* Sanfte, wehmütige Musik *
Einfach so zusammenkommen,
das wird in Uruguay nicht mehr gehen.
Die Strapazen der Reise
stecken Beatrice, Josef
und den Kindern in den Knochen.
Es ist bereits nach Mitternacht,
als Familie Almeida nach drei
langen Flügen in Halifax ankommt.
Charles, ihr neuer Nachbar,
erwartet sie schon.
Sofie.
Vor 24 Std. sind sie unter Tränen
in Turbenthal im Kanton Zürich
aufgebrochen.
Der Abschied hat ...
... nochmals klar vor Augen geführt,
dass es definitiv ist.
Aber es ist noch nicht
bis zum Herz durchgedrungen,
dass es eigentlich für immer ist.
Den Weg zum neuen Daheim
fährt Josef nicht zum ersten Mal.
Es hat wieder riesige Risse
auf diesen Strassen.
Seit zwei Jahren kommen die Almeidas
regelmässig hierher.
Jetzt wollen sie Wurzeln schlagen,
im eigenen Haus in der Nähe
des Ortes Tatamagouche.
Finally.
Die Familie
hat den ehemaligen Bauernhof
während der ersten Ferien in Kanada
entdeckt und gleich gekauft.
Ein paar Fliegen am Boden.
Steh auf, Robin.
Darunter ist eure Decke.
Wir können hier leben.
Es hat Betten, die wir
für heute noch anziehen müssen.
Auch einige Küchenutensilien
sind vorhanden.
Es ist etwas spartanisch,
aber das gefällt uns.
Es muss nicht so voll sein.
Es ist so weit okay.
Mir gefällt es hier,
es ist schön urchig.
Bea,
wir müssen die Betten noch anziehen.
Das Haus hat acht Zimmer.
Im ersten Stock durften sich
die Kinder je eines aussuchen.
Schau!
Das ist Sofies Zimmer.
Sind das alles deine Sachen?
- Ja.
Okay.
Was ist damit?
Haben wir das nicht gekauft?
Nein.
Nicht?
- Nein.
Die erste Etappe ins neue Leben
ist geschafft.
Morgen früh ...
... sind wir wieder munter.
Und voller Tatendrang.
Nicht, Bea?
- Ja, ja.
Aber jetzt langsam ...
Ab ins Bett!
Das haben wir uns verdient.
(Sacha)
Ihr dürft auspacken.
In Läufelfingen bei Familie Kunz
gibt es allen Grund zu feiern.
Ist gut?
So schnell geht es auf.
Bist du zufrieden?
- Ja. - Super.
Danke schön.
Die Zwillinge Timo und Noemi
werden 13.
Und die Familie kann endlich los
ins neue Heim an der Nordsee.
Doch zuerst heisst es
noch einmal Möbel schleppen.
Hast du es?
- Ja.
Die letzten Wochen kam die Familie
bei Sachas Schwiegermutter unter.
Das eigene Haus ist schon verkauft.
Wir werden sicher froh sein
über eigene vier Wände.
Aber im Grossen und Ganzen
lief es gut.
Es hätte schlimmer sein können.
Kevin, der grosse Sohn,
fährt zusammen mit seinem
Kollegen Davis den Möbelwagen.
Im Imbiss an der Nordsee ist Kevin
als Mitarbeiter fest eingeplant.
Jetzt kommt der Eselstreiber.
Hey, ihr zwei.
Habt ihr einen Plan gemacht?
So plus/minus, ja.
Ich weiss nichts von diesem Plan.
Mein Plan ist:
Wir arbeiten von vorne nach hinten.
Ihr müsst auf das Glas aufpassen.
* Treibende Musik *
Grossmutter Susanne
hilft nicht nur beim Einladen,
sie wandert gleich mit aus.
Sauschwer, nicht?
- Brutal.
Für das neue Zuhause hat sie sich
noch ein paar Möbel gekauft.
Wenn ich ankomme,
soll alles fixfertig sein.
Im Moment ist das ein Wunschtraum.
Pass auf mit dem Holz!
* Heitere, treibende Musik *
Dann geht es zum Abschiedsfest.
Nein, ist gut,
es ist nichts passiert.
Aber pass auf,
dass du nicht hinfällst!
Sacha und Brigitte haben für
die Feier eine Waldhütte gemietet.
10 Min.
Wir haben noch etwa 10 Min. Zeit
für die Vorbereitungen.
Ich habe Würste mitgebracht.
Das wird an der Nordsee
mein Standardjob sein:
Würste sortieren.
Ich kann schon mal etwas üben.
70 Leute haben sie eingeladen:
Familie, Freunde und Arbeitskollegen.
Die ganze Woche
war ein Abschiednehmen.
Alles tat man zum letzten Mal.
Das merkt man schon, ja.
Hallo ...
- Grüezi, hoi.
Fit und munter?
- Tipptopp.
Salü. - Hoi.
- Baschi, hoi.
Den Weg gefunden?
War er gut signalisiert?
Sacha und Brigitte
freuen sich auf die Chance,
die sich ihnen
mit dem Imbisswagen bietet.
Dafür lassen sie
viele Verwandte und Freunde zurück.
Ein Abschied mit gemischten Gefühlen.
* Glockenläuten *
Kein Tag wie jeder andere -
auch in Bern.
Na, Junior, nervös?
Ruedi und sein Sohn Michael
sind auf dem Weg ins Pentagon.
So heisst Ruedis Arbeitsort im Ver-
teidigungsdepartement im Volksmund.
Ja, super!
Scheiss-Rucksack!
Heute tritt Ruedi seinen Job
an seinen Sohn ab.
Willkommen. Alles Gute.
- Hoi, Katrin. Merci.
Einen guten Start bei uns.
Katrin Stucki
ist Ruedis Chefin im Kommando.
Sie hat Michael
aus verschiedenen Bewerbern
für Ruedis Nachfolge ausgewählt.
Er ist Jungschützenleiter,
er ist Schützenmeister.
Er kennt das Business,
das wir hier betreiben.
In diesem schon etwas speziellen
Bereich brauchen wir einen Schützen.
Dass sein Vater geht,
ist natürlich sehr schade.
Ich konnte sagen, was ich will,
und er hat eine Lösung gefunden.
Mal schauen,
ob das beim Junior auch so ist.
Einen guten Start bei uns.
- Merci. Bis nachher.
Das war bis jetzt mein Büro.
Jetzt kann Michael das neue Büro
übernehmen. Das passt so.
Es sind grosse Fussstapfen,
in die ich treten muss.
Im Keller ist noch Zeug,
das ich dir nicht gezeigt habe.
Rund zwölf Jahre lang
hatte Ruedi eine zivile Anstellung.
Zuerst in der Kommunikation,
später beim Schiesswesen.
Hier hinten hat es Mineralwasser.
- Zur freien Verfügung?
In leitender Funktion
war er für die traditionellen
Schweizer Schützenvereine zuständig.
Depot von den Kursen,
Jungschützenleiterkurse.
Schlüssel.
Hier drin sind auch noch zwei.
Kellerschlüssel 2.
Büroschlüssel.
Und das ist der Spedischlüssel.
- Der ist nicht aufgeführt.
* Tiefes Ausatmen *
Befreiend, echt befreiend.
Jetzt ist ... Nein.
Ja, das ist gut.
- Tipptopp.
Jetzt muss er auf diese Schlüssel
achten, nicht mehr ich.
Okay.
Passt. - Gut.
- Das machen wir so.
Noch ein paar Tage
die gewohnte Sicherheit in Bern.
Dann tauscht der 53-jährige Ruedi
seinen Schreibtisch beim Bund
gegen Säge und Hammer in Uruguay.
Anderthalb Jahre plant er
für den Bau der Ferienlodge.
Dann sollten
die ersten zahlenden Gäste kommen.
Ende Monat
erhalte ich meinen letzten Lohn.
Ende Juli
ist das bei meiner Frau der Fall.
Dann geht es ans Eingemachte,
dann muss was gehen.
Uns steht nicht
endlos Geld zur Verfügung.
Das Budget steht.
Darin sind zwar
auch Reserven enthalten,
aber irgendwann
ist dann auch fertig.
* Leichte, beschwingte Musik *
Der erste Morgen
im neuen Heim von Familie Almeida.
Bis vor zwei Tagen servierten sie
um diese Zeit in der Schweiz
das Frühstück für ihre Gäste.
Ganz dicke Vögel!
- Pst! Nicht so schreien!
Eins ...
- Eins, zwei, drei ...
Ich sehe nur drei.
Nein,
da ist noch eines in der Mitte.
Die Schuhe und die Taucherbrillen
kommen nach hinten.
Hier drin ist Papis Bild.
Und es ist noch ganz!
Es bekommt einen Ehrenplatz.
Du musst noch
einen Nagel einschlagen.
Ist nicht dort ein Nagel?
Das sind meine besten Freunde.
Unglaublich, dass es noch ganz ist.
Ich wollte die Schweiz
eigentlich nie verlassen.
Aber ...
... mit der Zeit ...
Wir haben darüber gesprochen usw.
Mit der Zeit dachte ich ...
Erstens sehnt er sich sehr danach.
Und als wir herkamen,
sahen wir die Weite des Landes -
unglaublich schön.
Dann war es für mich klar,
das Herz war schon fast angekommen.
68 ha - fast 100 Fussballfelder.
So viel Land
können die Almeidas ihr Eigen nennen.
Come on.
Kommt, wir gehen.
Jungs, einsteigen!
* Idyllische Musik *
Mit dem Auto ist es eine
Viertelstunde bis ins nächste Dorf.
Tatamagouche -
ein Ort mit gut 800 Einwohnern.
Direkt an der Durchgangsstrasse
liegt der zukünftige Arbeitsplatz
der Auswanderer:
Keine 12 Std. nach ihrer Ankunft in
Kanada haben sie ihren ersten Termin.
Hello.
Sie sind mit ihrem Makler Ralf und
dem bisherigen Besitzer verabredet.
Jim führte das Motel 17 Jahre lang
zusammen mit seiner Frau Sue.
Altershalber wollen sie es abgeben.
Perfect.
Den Kaufvertrag haben Almeidas
bereits unterschrieben.
Aber bevor
sie das Geld überweisen,
wollen sie
das Gebäude noch einmal begutachten.
Das Haus wurde 1967 gebaut.
Das letzte Rührei hatten Jim und Sue
vor einem halben Jahr zubereitet.
Im Winter
hatten sie das Motel geschlossen.
* Glockenläuten *
Es hat 18 Zimmer -
gut dreimal so viele
wie das Bed and Breakfast
der Almeidas in der Schweiz.
Wir haben es schon einmal gesehen,
das ist nicht neu.
Aber man muss noch einiges machen.
Es hat viel Potenzial.
- Ja, sagen wir es mal so.
Vielleicht mal
ein bisschen malen ...
Ein wenig modernisieren.
... neue Lampen, solche Dinge.
Und schon macht es
einen ganz anderen Eindruck.
Die Aussicht
auf den Fluss ist der Hammer.
Man müsste
nur noch rauslaufen können.
Wir überlegen uns,
einen Sitzplatz anzulegen.
Für das Haus müssen sie umgerechnet
350'000 Fr. auf den Tisch legen.
Viel Geld, aber für Josef stimmt es.
Auch hier unten
die roten Backsteine ...
Die sind aber noch schön.
- Unten blättert es ab.
Das muss man noch so ...
- Du ... - Ja!
Es ist kein Hilton, Schatz.
- Es ist was?
Kein Hilton.
- Kein Fünfsternehotel.
Ach so.
Ist es nicht. Noch nicht.
- Ich weiss.
Eins nach dem anderen.
Dich wird es auch noch stören.
Ralf, deine Einschätzung.
Für kanadische Verhältnisse
ist es nicht mal so schlecht, oder?
Nein, das ist gut,
das ist überdurchschnittlich.
Im Emmental lädt Ruedi zum Ausstand.
Ich möchte mich kurz fassen.
Im Rückblick
war es eine sehr schöne Zeit.
Es war v.a. schön,
mit euch zusammenzuarbeiten -
mit den einen etwas länger,
mit den anderen weniger lang.
Katrin, Kompliment, ich hatte noch
nie eine so gute Chefin wie dich.
Ein ganz herzliches Dankeschön,
merci!
Wir wünschen dir,
und auch dir, Susanne,
alles Gute auf dem Weg
Richtung Uruguay.
Es wird sicher
nicht immer einfach werden.
Aber ich denke,
ihr werdet erfolgreich sein.
Ruedi, komm bitte nach vorne.
* Ruedi lacht. *
Ein richtiger Berner braucht
natürlich auch eine Bernerfahne,
nicht nur die Schweizerfahne.
Die wird sowieso gehisst. Geil!
Sehr schön.
Wunderbar.
Ruedi, merci vielmals für alles.
- Merci vielmals.
* Applaus *
* Wehmütige Musik *
Trag Sorge zu dir.
- Du auch.
Bis in fünf Jahren.
- Ja, versprochen.
Ich bin emotional
schon etwas aufgewühlt.
Ich war vorhin den Tränen nahe.
Aber ... jetzt probieren wir es.
Für euch hätten wir
schon noch ein Zimmer frei.
Susannes Tränen
werden nicht die letzten sein,
denn der Abschied
hat für die Emmentaler erst begonnen.
Stehen wir auf.
Toi, toi.
- Merci vielmals.
Auf das Leben!
Nur noch alles ins Auto packen,
dann geht es für den 50-jährigen
Sacha und seine Frau Brigitte
endlich los.
Der grosse Sohn Kevin
ist mit dem Möbelwagen
schon auf dem Weg
nach Norddeutschland.
Die Zwillinge Timo und Noemi hingegen
bleiben noch bei ihrer Grossmutter -
bis das Schuljahr zu Ende ist.
Dachtest du, er bleibe hier?
- Ja.
Der Abschied von den Kindern
ist schon schwierig.
Ja.
Komm rein!
* Pfiff *
So ist gut.
Tschüss.
Also ... - Tschüss.
- Ist gut? - Ja.
Viel Spass
und morgen ein gutes Turnier.
Tschüss, Timo. Ist gut?
Es ist nicht für lange.
In sechs Wochen
kommen Timo und Noemi nach,
zusammen mit Grossmutter Susanne.
Okay.
Macht es bitte kurz.
Tschüss.
- Nicht schon wieder!
Nein, ist okay.
Wir gehen.
Mach noch winke, winke
Uh!
Hoppla!
Hast du alles?
- Ich hoffe es, ja.
Tschüss zusammen!
- Tschüss! - Tschüss!
Tschau. - Tschau-tschau!
- Tschau-tschau!
* Der Hund bellt. *
* Gemütliche Musik *
900 km weiter nördlich ist
der Möbelwagen schon fast entladen.
Der ist verdammt schwer.
Kevin ist vor ein paar Stunden
angekommen.
Gemeinsam mit seinem Kollegen Davis
ist er die Nacht durchgefahren.
Hast du ihn?
Ja.
Momentan fühlt es sich
noch wie Ferien an.
Aber es wird dann schon
zu einem Zuhause werden.
Es ist ein komisches Gefühl,
aber völlig in Ordnung.
Nur noch ein paar Kilometer,
dann haben es
auch Sacha und Brigitte geschafft.
Jetzt sind wir halt
wieder im Norden. - Ja.
Endlich zu Hause.
- Endlich daheim. So ist es.
Auf diesen Moment
haben wir lange gewartet.
Sie sind am Ziel -
nach 10 Std. auf der Autobahn.
Ja, Maite!
Warten, Bubi, warten ...
So ist gut.
Hund Falco und Katze Roxy
haben die lange Fahrt
scheinbar gut überstanden.
Du kennst ja den Weg.
Falco, nein, nein, hier durch.
Hopp, hier durch!
Oh,
wir müssen uns hier durchzwängen.
Hallo! - Hallo!
- Hallo!
Wim.
- Hallo.
Herzlich willkommen!
Hallo.
Die Baselbieter haben
bereits Freunde, die sie erwarten.
Alles klar. Super.
Grüss dich.
Nachbar André und seine Familie
haben schon einen Teil der Möbel
zusammengebaut.
Susannes Bett
und die Nachttischschränke stehen.
Was, schon?
- Wirklich? - Ja.
Super.
Und jetzt Vollgas.
- Wir schrauben die noch zusammen.
Komm zu mir.
Schau mal. Schau mal hier.
Es ist ein Nachhausekommen,
es ist schön.
Freunde, die warten und helfen -
es ist cool.
Wirklich, wirklich cool.
Hat du den Backofen angeschlossen?
- Wer, ich?
Ja, komm. Ich kann kochen, ja!
Ich doch nicht.
- Du doch nicht, nein.
André wohnt mit seiner Familie
gleich gegenüber.
Die Schweizer haben ihn erst
vor ein paar Monaten kennengelernt,
als Sacha und Brigitte
das Haus renovierten.
Ah, cool.
Es war Liebe auf den ersten Blick.
Die Familie
hat uns so herzlich empfangen.
Wir wurden aufgenommen,
als würden wir uns 20 Jahre kennen.
* Miauen *
* Fröhliche Musik *
Umzug gelungen:
Einen besseren Start hätten sie
sich nicht wünschen können.
An der Tatamagouche Regional Academy
beginnt eine neue Schulwoche.
Die Busse mit den Schülern
kommen erst in einer halben Stunde.
Familie Almeida aber ist schon da.
Es ist kühl.
Für Robin, Sofie und André ist es der
erste Schultag in der neuen Heimat.
Hast du die Unterlagen?
- Ja.
Ich möchte noch eine Foto machen.
Stellt euch zwischen die Pfosten.
- Geht zwischen die Pfosten.
Ja, stellt euch mal nebeneinander.
Ist gut?
- Wartet noch. Bleib stehen, Robin!
Josef und Beatrice haben die Kinder
vor zwei Monaten hier angemeldet.
Anders als in Turbenthal gehen
alle drei in dasselbe Schulhaus.
Good morning.
- Willkommen.
Willkommen? Thank you.
Schulleiter Brian Holmes
erwartet die Familie schon.
Fine, thank you.
Morning.
So, Robin?
- This is Robin, yes.
André?
- Yes.
And Sofie. - Yes.
- Willkommen.
Okay, Robin, just follow me.
Robin. Jawohl.
Schau mal hier.
"Herzlich willkommen!"
- Genau.
Robin? This ist Miss Mac.
Nice to meet you.
Der achtjährige Robin
versteht kaum ein Wort.
In der Primarschule hatte er
nur ein paar Monate Frühenglisch.
Miss heisst Frau,
und Mac ist der Namen.
Miss Mac.
Und André ist gleich nebenan,
gleich dort drüben.
Are you hungry, André?
- No.
Sie sagte, du sollst eintreten
und dich hinsetzen.
Und wenn was ist, sagst du es,
André ist gleich im nächsten Zimmer.
Ja. - Okay, ist gut?
- Ja.
Sehen wir uns später?
Tschüss, viel Spass.
Ein Kuss oder lieber nicht?
Willst du?
- Ist mir egal.
Gut.
Ich glaube, ich bin nervöser als er.
Oder wie André auch -
sie gehen einfach rein
und machen das. Wirklich cool.
* Stimmengewirr *
André, wir gehen.
Tschüss.
- Tschau.
Mach's gut, Schatz.
Wir holen euch dann ab.
Sie stehen auf für die Hymne?
Das muss ich sehen.
Das ist sehr speziell.
Und von der Lehrerin haben wir uns
auch noch nicht verabschiedet.
(Flüsternd) Schau mal hier.
Aufstehen, André!
# O Canada!
# Our home and native land.
Sie stehen für die Hymne auf.
# True patriot love in all ...
# O Canada
we stand on guard for thee.
Damit habe ich nicht gerechnet.
Das ist ziemlich amerikanisch.
Aber ... es ist gut.
Sie müssen nicht mitsingen,
das ist auch gut.
Gehen wir schnell hoch zu Sofie.
Mal schauen,
ob dort auch alles gut ist.
Hi, findest du dich zurecht?
- Ja, ist gut.
Okay.
"Ja, ist gut" - also ja.
Gehen wir runter?
Das klang nicht glücklich, oje.
Der erste Schultag: für Beatrice
fast aufregender als für ihre Kinder.
Sie werden es schon schaffen.
Diesseits des grossen Teichs
beginnt für Ruedi das Abenteuer.
Kann ich noch etwas Kuchen haben?
Du musst essen,
solange du noch kannst.
Danke.
In Uruguay möchte Ruedi
mit dem Bau der Ferienlodge beginnen.
Wir haben ihn schon verloren.
- Wo ist er?
Er fliegt mit einem alten Kollegen.
Seine Frau Susanne
bleibt noch vier Monate hier
und verdient weiter Geld
für ihr Bauprojekt.
Ich bleibe hier.
Nach Montevideo, korrekt?
- Ja.
Das Gepäck, bitte schön.
Ich habe mich darauf eingestellt,
dass ich hierbleibe.
Ich bin froh, dass er jetzt
mit der Arbeit beginnen kann
und es bei uns allgemein
etwas ruhiger wird.
Denn es war eine happige Zeit.
Soll ich dich aufgeben?
Kann ich als Handgepäck mitgehen?
Tschüss sagen?
Tschau, trag Sorge zu dir.
Achte auf dich und bleib sauber!
- Ich probiere es.
Ihre drei Söhne und Susannes Eltern
sind zum Flughafen mitgekommen.
Tschüss.
- Tschau, trag Sorge zu dir.
Trag Sorge zu dir! Grosi ...
Tschau.
Alles Gute.
- Achte auf dich.
Gleichfalls.
- Merci.
Trag Sorge zu dir.
- Gleichfalls. Merci.
Achte gut auf dich.
Ist gut?
17 Std. mit Zwischenstopp -
so lange ist Ruedi
nach Uruguay unterwegs.
Ich habe zum Glück
noch die Jungs hier.
Ja.
* Melancholische Musik *
Ha, das sagst du jetzt.
Tschüss zusammen!
In Kanada bekommen Almeidas
regelmässig Anrufe aus der Schweiz.
Almeida.
Grüezi, Herr Breite.
Wann brauchen Sie ein Zimmer?
Die beiden
verwalten noch immer die Buchungen
für ihr Bed and Breakfast
in Turbenthal.
Ja, einen Moment bitte.
Für einen Monat? Oi, oi, oi.
Für einen Monat wird es schwierig.
Viele Tage sind schon ausgebucht.
Okay, alles klar.
Einen schönen Tag. Adieu. Merci.
Josefs Mutter
führt jetzt zwar das Gästehaus,
aber sie hat mit den Buchungen
nach wie vor Probleme.
Wir nehmen die Anrufe schon an.
- Das muss aufhören.
Wir leiten die Anrufen auf sie um.
Dafür bin ich nicht ausgewandert.
Im Moment war es am einfachsten,
es so zu lassen.
Nach und nach werden wir sie mehr
miteinbeziehen bei den Buchungen.
Mit zwei Zimmern weniger
wird es dann schon klappen.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Trotz Doppelbelastung -
ein guter Tag für Josef und Beatrice.
Denn der Kauf des Motels
steht unmittelbar vor dem Abschluss.
Welcome to Tatamagouche.
Thank you very much.
Schau mal wie schön!
So süss.
Das Einzige, was noch fehlt,
sind die Schlüssel.
Oops.
I'd take the car, too.
- I gotta take those off there, too.
And there you go.
- Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Anderthalb Jahre haben sie
auf diesen Tag hingearbeitet.
Again.
- Again, yes.
Perfect, thank you.
Wir sind Besitzer
eines grossen Motels.
Das ist echt cool.
Es gibt aber auch viel Arbeit,
viel zu lernen.
Wir müssen
wirklich noch viel lernen.
Ich freue mich irrsinnig auf
die neue Aufgabe. Das kommt gut.
Schatz ...
Jim und Sue wollen den beiden noch
mit Rat und Tat zur Seite stehen,
bis sich Almeidas
im Motel zurechtfinden.
We also need the address
of this Pearl Drive Hotel.
* Ruhige Klänge *
Unterdessen geht auch
der erste Schultag zu Ende.
Heute holen Josef und Beatrice
die Kinder ab.
Künftig sollen sie
mit dem Schulbus fahren.
Da kommen unsere Jungs.
Hallo!
Wo ist deine Jacke,
wo ist dein Pullover?
Es ist heiss.
- Hoi, Mami.
Hoi, Schatz.
Wir hatten Sport.
- Alles okay?
Du hattest Sport?
- Ich schwitzte wie verrückt.
Schnell. Schnell, schnell.
Sonst erkältest du dich.
Wie war's?
- Gut.
War's gut? - Ja.
- Hast du was verstanden? - Ja.
Echt? Und wie war das Mittagessen?
- Gut.
Super! Das macht mich glücklich.
Eine heisst Sophie.
- Ernsthaft?
Aber mit ph.
- Okay. Gut.
Die erste Hürde
haben die Kinder gemeistert.
Es ist eine grosse Erleichterung,
dass es so gut funktioniert.
Wenn wir das mit dem Bus
noch hinkriegen,
sollte alles seinen Gang gehen.
Ich bin zufrieden.
* Ruhige Musik *
* Gemütliche Musik *
Zum Sonnenuntergang
zieht es Sacha und Brigitte ans Meer.
Willst du da durch?
Ja, noch durch den Hafen.
Direkt am Kutterhafen
steht der Imbisswagen,
den sie in ein paar
Wochen übernehmen wollen.
"Dorumer Hafenterrasse" -
das haben sie neu gemacht.
Stimmt.
Der ehemalige Vertreter
und die gelernte Krankenschwester
wagen den Sprung ins kalte Wasser.
Eigentlich schon speziell,
dass wir dann ab Juli hier sind.
Nicht mehr Ferien, sondern arbeiten.
Genau,
aber es ist ein schönes Arbeiten.
Wenn man die Landschaft
betrachtet ...
Einen schöneren Arbeitsplatz
gibt es nicht.
Ja, so ist es.
Sieben Tage in der Woche wollen sie
hier Pommes und Currywurst verkaufen.
Vorher aber muss der Wagen
noch mit ihrem Logo beklebt werden.
Es fehlen noch
die ganzen Beschriftungen.
Auf der Seite nichts, oder?
Nein,
ausser man befestigt einen Kleber.
25 Jahre
steht der Imbiss schon am Hafen.
Jetzt will ihn der Besitzer abgeben.
Unten bringt nicht viel.
Ausser du machst unten
etwas Grosses.
Ja, das können wir
dann auch noch machen.
Die Kinderscooter sind auch noch da.
Ins Rollen gebracht wurden
die Auswanderungspläne der Familie
in den letzten Ferien.
Es war dort oben,
ganz links in der Ecke,
ganz klein angeschrieben,
dass er den Wagen verkaufen will.
Timo hat das gesehen
und ist auf uns zugekommen.
Wir sassen gerade hier
bei einem dieser Tische.
Er kam damit zu uns,
und so begann die Geschichte
mit diesem Wagen.
Deshalb nahmen wir Kontakt auf.
* Sehnsüchtige Musik *
Familie Kunz und die Nordsee:
Was einst als Ferienflirt begann,
könnte zur ernsthaften
Liebesbeziehung werden.
Vielleicht so.
- Du musst es drehen.
Mhm.
Grosse Party am Wattenmeer
in der nächsten Folge.
Sacha und Brigitte
übernehmen den Imbisswagen.
Den Schlüssel haben wir.
Jetzt brauchen sie dringend
noch den passenden Wurstlieferanten.
Der Eindruck ist sehr positiv.
- Der Weg ist noch etwas weit.
In Uruguay könnte Ruedi
mit der Ferienlodge loslegen.
Doch er kann sich noch nicht
mit der Baufirma einigen.
Der Baumeister wollte bauen,
aber ich sagte: "Nein, so nicht."
Und im Motel in Kanada
geht nichts mehr.
Irgendwas hat er verpfuscht.
Jetzt heisst es: "No internet."
Unerwarteter Stress
für Josef und Beatrice:
Bereits tauchen die ersten Gäste auf.
Hello.
# U si stige i Flüger, flüge
mit de Vögu furt, chöme nüme hei.
# U si löh hie aues zrugg
uf dr Suechi für es neus Dahei.
# Si gö hüt no uf u dervo.
# Uf u dervo.
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Philipp Schlatter - 2020